hello everyone it's wonderful to be here
amazing audience even more amazing
speakers it's it's so hard to go after
three of youth it's yeah it's it's tough
so my name is ferno's
and I'm an engineering director here in
LA at snap when I was talking to the
organizers of this event the very first
time they said they're looking for
storytelling around those sort of
pivotal moments that help shape shape
our lives and I think as you see there
there are several moments like that they
all leave their marks but at that moment
for me what hit me was this experience I
had that has has helped shaped my life
from one of those events and I think I'm
just gonna go with it and I think
Samantha talked about this as well so
the story goes back to my high school
years when I was skiing I had skied from
very early ages and you know you go
through those beautiful first few
sessions where you know you start with
like I don't know what I'm doing - I'm
in control like I think I've got it
covered and it feels amazing it's
fulfilling and fun and obviously future
changes when you're learning anything
new right the first set of changes come
really fast low-hanging fruits and then
it gets slower and slower and that's
fine well understood but when I got to
high school I think I was self-conscious
enough to realize that oh I'm not
changing that much I'm plateauing so I
went to this great instructor and I
asked him to start working with me we
had their first day together and at the
end of the day he said I think I know
why you're not good which first you
don't say that if you're an educator
you're a teacher you're an instructor
just don't say that some of us are tough
enough to you know hang in there and
keep plowing through some of us aren't
luckily I was one of those first groups
of people so he said let's go and
there's a group of quote/unquote cool
kids where we go and ski together at the
end of the day for an hour the problem
is one I'm not a cool kid - I don't hang
out with cool kids so immediately that
was a red
but I figured I'll go with it he knows
why I'm not good we went and we hit this
point where it was called and within the
slopes was called the wall wasn't
released back then it was called the
wall for very similar reasons it was a
vertical drop snowy icy and I would not
be hitting that part of the slope in my
right mind set it was just not a thing I
do not even scary it was crazy so we hit
it everybody's lining up sort of
perpendicular to the drop and they go
one by one a couple of them fall and I'm
the last one and I stood up there like
imagine high school tough ages and the
group of cool kids staring at you and I
can't remember how many minutes it was
but I think it was that gaze of the cool
kid that got me to just go with it and
it was horrible I had the worst fall
I've ever had my ski was in one place
the Hat was in another snow in my ears
but I think something amazing happened
at that point and that was just getting
a little more comfortable with looking
silly and clumsy and you know in front
of a bunch of people watching you just
falling and by the way disclaimer I'm
not comfortable with that in life I got
comfortable with that at that moment
that don't circumstances when I was
skiing and I really helped actually push
me forward I got better and being a
somewhat sentimental kid I took a note
of that and thought you know I'm a
risk-averse person I get into my comfort
zone and I plateau and I have to push
myself I have to force myself and I
tried to think about that when I get to
those tough decisions that I need to
make and what I remember is there's a
there's a few instances in life where I
think that experience kind of came in
handy and helped push me outside of my
comfort zone after college I was
thinking about you know do I want to
stay back in my home country or go
abroad come to the US and study here and
it was somewhat it was scary
thought I had to go to a country where I
didn't know that many people it was a
different language it was in a place
where I have to get a visa where my
parents couldn't visit me where I
couldn't go back due to the risk of not
being able to come back and finish my
studies but I decided this was you know
one of those once-in-a-lifetime sort of
opportunities so I decided to go with it
and by the way I'm gonna ruin the story
I'm still here so like it worked out
there was really really hard
you know I was staying home that's what
people did back home you stay with your
parents at college pampered you know
parents are taking care of you making
sure your day-to-day needs are met and
all of a sudden I'm landing in LAX in
this new world and I gotta take it but
myself it was really really hard but
fulfilling and amazing and you learn so
much so many new experiences that I
would have never had before throughout
those those years as I was working on my
PhD you know I was a good student and
you had to get A's and that was I had of
covered but after a couple of years in
grad school I started thinking that this
is not for me getting my PhD postdoc
academia it's just not cutting it and
you might think big deal people do
something else but within my network of
friends and with my family like that
that was not something we did like you
go you go all the way you go to the end
you you know you don't quit and I think
that final straw for me came when one I
got a cold call or cold email from
Google recruiters that was exciting
Google was a big deal back then but you
know there's a new hot company and I had
a paper submitted to this most
prestigious conference and my regular me
would be checking that website every day
do that get accepted I get accepted and
I was not doing that at all
and I learned that my favorite was
accepted through a congratulations email
from my advisor that was a really bad
time I was not caring and so again going
back to hitting that wall the
perpendicular wall worried about how I'm
gonna be judged as I quit I decided to
jump and go and give it a try and I put
that PhD on hold again I'm joining the
story it's still on hold
and yeah I joined I joined the industry
and it was amazing it was humbling I
knew how to be a good student but I
didn't know how to work among a bunch of
people who for the most part were
smarter than me
better than me more hard-working more
experienced better just better but at
the same time it meant that at those
pivotal years the beginning of my career
I got to be surrounded by people who
were ready to me and I got to learn from
them and I think that's huge and within
those years I made sure it at every
through three years when I was on the
project and I was you know going from
the first few months of I'm an idiot I
don't know what I'm doing - I've got it
covered the moment I hit that point the
moment people were coming to me asking
me questions it was time to move on
switch projects do something new get
into that zone of not being comfortable
get into that zone of questioning
whether you belong I'm learning that
that's a good area to be at and finally
two years ago I left that first company
joined snap and it was everything I
thought it'd be I didn't know anything
about app development snapchat was used
by kids that were cool and hip and again
I wasn't one it's a repeating pattern
here
and I decided to join and it was really
really hard to start the first three
months but as usual that repeating
pattern you know you pick it up you
learn those new skills you question
whether you belong you question whether
you're smart enough you're good enough
you're creative enough and you figure it
out
and so I think the lesson for me is we
are lucky enough to live in part of the
world and at times where we're given so
many chances like you can't make a
mistake big enough that you can't go
back from very easily you can like if
you try hard enough but it's really hard
so the lesson for me has always been
just get out of your comfort zone the
moment you think I'm really good at this
at this I've got it covered it's time to
jump
[Applause]